what do we do when we have a core when
we compensate and we do it in bad ways
jessica jones in her show compensates by
having lots of random sex she's been
mined raped by the villain and so as a
consequence she can't connect to other
people emotionally so she has a lot of
mindless sex yes in this show Elliott
score wound is I'm alone in powerless so
he lies he's a liar this is important
because when you create a character with
a core wound you want at least three or
four attributes they have that are not
good but they're compensations for their
wound there are things we wish we didn't
do but because we're wounded we do bad
things he lies so in the deep lot when
he's dealing with his shrink he lies to
his shrink his shrink knows that he's
not telling the truth but she asked him
why do you feel so alienated Elliott now
Elliott in his head is telling her why
watch the show but he's actually not
saying a word but as he's talking in his
head the audience is loving what he's
saying because why does he say he's the
way he is he says and this is what we
always do when we compensate for a wound
you know why I'm this way because the
world is screwing and let me tell you
how the world is screwing our heroes are
all screwy our heroes are Donald Trump
our heroes are Bill Cosby our heroes are
people like that that lie they're
hypocrites that are horrible our heroes
and our and our world is full of people
who lie and also we have shitty we have
crappy movies we entertain ourselves we
dope ourselves we get into debt he
doesn't actually say any of this to her
what he says to her is I'm fine so we're
staying the disconnect and was seeing
what Elliott needs to heal and we're
seeing why Elliott is wounded he does
understand with her why he likes her
which is that she's warm this is why
he's there at all now she asked him did
you go to Angela's birthday party
remember our be story plot can you
connect emotionally people that's what
the shrink is there to help him try to
do this is critical in the story
remember
in the mystery thriller it is the
emotional change of the hero that helps
him soft the crime if he does not
connect emotionally Elliott will never
ever succeed in this pilot okay and
remember this is also a beat and in a
beat we have a protagonist and
antagonist and a fight and the fight in
this scene is Elliot will you tell the
truth Elliot's actually antagonist in
the speed and Elliot says yeah I will
but he doesn't and they fight and he
finally wins and that's the climax of
that little beat each beat has that
conflict right so let's go back to the a
story when he gets back to his office we
now meet finally both the distraction
villain and the real villain here they
come ee corporation comes to Elliot's
company because they're so angry they've
been hacked and we meet who we think is
the villain Terry Colby this old white
guy with a tie and our but guess what
he's not the real villain remembering a
mystery thriller there is a distraction
pot and a real crime pod we also in this
scene are going to meet the real villain
but he's not who we think Terry Colby is
the guy we think is a villain and so by
the way is Elliot because Elliot is a
pawn in a mystery thriller the hero is a
pawn of the villain he is a very
unsuccessful guy who is being used by
the real villain to evil ends and that's
true for Elliot but then at the very end
of his scene notice who Elliot meets
along with the old fat white guy is this
young sleek beautiful dude in a perfect
suit his name is tyrell wellick and as
he goes by le and he says hey Elliot how
you doing it ah I'm tyrell wellick hey
man I'm just about your age I noticed
you're using a certain kind of software
I used to do that when I was a hacker oh
yeah I was a hacker anyway it's great to
meet you I'll talk to you
later he is the real valid and we will
not know that until the end of our story
just as you don't know in Le
confidential who the real villain is
till the end of the story just as you
don't know insult who the real villain
is till the end of the story always true
in a mystery so now act 2 opens with our
a storyline and what is Elliott saying
he's saying I wish I could save the
world but I can't why can't I save the
world now we're gonna see explicitly why
he's wounded not all stories do this but
I urge you to do it if you can because
if you can show the wound happening to
your hero you will have gobs of sympathy
for him what a normal people do when
they get sad this is what Elliot asks
will they reach out to other people but
I can't do that and we suddenly flash on
the screen his mother and him when he
was 4 tied to a high chair and her
beating him explicit the core wound this
is why he cannot connect this is the
core wound in action right and don't
think you can ever get away from this
you can't I don't care if you're writing
sci-fi you need to show this core wound
and it's bleeding this is true for Don
Draper and madmen this is true for
Walter White this is true for Tyrion
Lannister in Game of Thrones what do you
think his core wound is by the way right
daddy didn't love me well look what he's
gonna be doing he kills his dad in a
crossbow why his death in the toilet and
many other terrible things because of
his core won't rust and Marty and true
detective have core wounds that are
critical to enjoying the story second
season of true detected not so much so
we see that Elliot was hurt by someone
who was supposed to be his strongest
caretaker and then that happens to us it
screws us up terribly I'm alone he's
thinking I'm powerless it also
underlines all four of our story lines
the be sterling really connect to Angela
no so we see him using what here comes
another compensation for his core wound
he not only lies what else do we do when
bleeding we do other things he uses
morphine he blanks out his pain with
drugs we see him using morphine now what
else do we see he uses sex as a way of
escaping a bad reflector character comes
in now reflected characters just
characters that reflects something that
he was should learn or what he shouldn't
learn this bad reflector is his dealer
she's also a girl and she also tempts
him to do ecstasy with her and he
doesn't want to do it but he does it he
is moving away from healing in all
aspects were getting into the second act
now guys we don't have time tonight to
talk about another structural issue
called the BM moc structure which is but
you should know they're five times in a
television our pilot when the hero is
asked to heal a little bit these are
five dramatic climax s in every great
television story if your story doesn't
have them the rhythms not going to be
there there's a BMOC pattern in movies
it's more complicated in television
again I go into this in my foundations
lecture on University of story it's a
critical pattern but it's it's for
another lecture but he is moving away
from healing he's moving away from
connecting in every aspect of his life
right now ok so we had a little bit more
of a deep pot but then we get Angela at
the office saying Elliot come back I
need you something terrible has happened
this is the inciting incident because
what is it it's our be story can Elliot
help Angela really connect to her
emotionally she says I need your help
when he gets there guess what's happened
there is a huge attack on the evil
corporation and remember Elliot's
company is supposed to keep them safe
and it's an attack that the hacker
already there can't solve Angela can't
sob they need Elliot superpower Elliot's
boss comes in he brushes Angeles side
again remember she's being treated like
a woman who knows nothing and now we see
if you're watching the episode that
Elliot gives us all these cool I call it
the we
the story because it's a pleasure for
you he tells us this isn't just a DDoS
attack this is a toi attack it's a boot
sequence attack it's a rootkit all of
these things let us know that this story
really is not giving us bull it's
telling us the truth about this world
and we're excited when you tell the
truth about a world we want to see that
when you research your story guys don't
set a story in Pakistan and you being a
CIA agent if you've never been to
Pakistan if you're not a CIA agent I'm
going to know it's horribly stupid
before two minutes are up Sam has great
technical support for this show anyway
so they go down to the server farm with
great ticking clocks with great
sequences Elliot actually solves the
issue and he gets the attack isolated
the hacker he stops but guess what else
happens
you